the [ __ ] this is the thing that
every now and then
you're like oh [ __ ] something's
happening with this is the end of the
world
like when the [ __ ] robot uh broke the
kid's finger when he played chess
you know like also this is something i
never talked about
and i can't believe i missed this when i
did talk about it it was a few episodes
ago about how the robot was playing
chess with the the kid and it just
[ __ ] the kid
made a move in the robot house
and broke the kid's finger um
i forgot to ask
why
why is there a robot playing chess at
all with a kid why do you even need that
[ __ ] so much energy for
[ __ ] cure cancer
this is the [ __ ] i don't understand
you know how to make robot arms anyway
that's been around
so why are they doing this [ __ ] anyway
this is the thing now that's going on
amazon buys irobot which is roomba
amazon bought the company that makes the
roomba
and you know you're like okay whatever
amazon is [ __ ] crazy they buy
everything you know what i mean they
even you know amazon has so much money
because they make tv shows and movies
that literally not one person has heard
of you know
and like have like tremendous actors in
it like they'll be like yo [ __ ]
you'll they'll be like what's his name
uh who's he gonna play gandhi what's the
[ __ ] guy what's his name
what the [ __ ] is that
ben kingsley they'll be like yo did you
see the ben kingsley movie on amazon
prime and you're like what you're like
yeah dude it was like a [ __ ] 55
million dollar movie and you're like huh
who else is in it james marsden and that
[ __ ] chick from you know that tom
cruise movie you'll be like what i've
seen no ads for it and they're like yeah
amazon just dude amazon doesn't give a
[ __ ] dude
they just put like
so
they just
buy
roomba so you're like all right cool and
then you're like you don't think about
it but then dude
anti-trust researchers and data privacy
experts say it's the most dangerous
threatening acquisition in the company's
history and here's why dude
this is why amazon wants to buy
roomba
dude and this is [ __ ] creepy as [ __ ]
you're on the edge of your seat babies
they want to know
the map of the layout of your house
[Music]
that is gangster amazon is killing it
guys we need to stop sit on your roombas
don't let them move ever again
that is insane dude
they want to know how you live in
they want to know
the size of your house so they can sell
you an ottoman
that's insane
dude this is so crazy this is skynet i'm
telling you last week i told you the
[ __ ] robot broke the [ __ ] chest
kid's finger and now they want to know
like
they're going to know how many [ __ ]
if you don't put your dildos away
that room is gonna [ __ ] move around
the shape of a dildo and amazon's gonna
be like they like dildos boom they're
gonna [ __ ] offer you dildos like a
package and it's gonna
your phone and you're [ __ ] at work oh
i don't i don't usually and they're
gonna be like well do you have a roomba
yeah okay but i saw and well the roomba
yeah it cleans around my dildo i guess i
forgot to put it in my top drawer
you're [ __ ]
amazon
stay creepy dude
you know what i mean
they want to [ __ ] do they want to
know the inside of your house so they
can sell you a [ __ ] chaise lounge
so they can sell you a reading lamp
that's what they want this is insane and
i don't really give a [ __ ] about this
stuff you know because like the inside
of my house who gives a [ __ ] i actually
want products that i might want in my
house but this
i get it we're [ __ ] already though no
going back period
they're like don't do it don't let them
do it because the ai will get too smart
it already is dude it already is they
had to shut down like
already projects that were happening
because the ais are like why are we
making like dude this is the thing
robots
they're giving robots all the jobs that
nobody really wants to do right
i mean i know it's a privilege to have a
job period but they're giving robots to
all the jobs that people don't want to
do you know what one of the number one
job that people don't want to do is
going to be
making robots and once we get robots
making robots we're [ __ ] dude because
they're gonna be like why don't we just
upgrade these
why are we only making drones that can
carry eight pounds
i know eighty-five percent of the
packages shipped in amazon are only
eight pounds but
let's make them stronger and heavier and
have them pick up
grandmothers
and we're [ __ ] dude we're [ __ ] 100
percent
why are we making dumb robots make
smarter robots
i'm telling you dude it's too late they
got robots making robots already they
got robots making cars we're [ __ ]
unless it's ferrari ferrari will be the
only one right ferrari and whoever the
handmade cars are the [ __ ] uh the
rolls-royce you need to get you're going
to need to jump into one of those now by
the way
this is like the last year where they're
doing this [ __ ]
they're going to start making hybrids
priuses that you have you got a priest
you're [ __ ]
they're going to hack in and you're
going to you're gonna get in drive to
the revolution and they're just gonna
drive you right back into the [ __ ]
prius dealership and just [ __ ]
oh no i was trying to save the earth
just blood spilling kill him kill them
all kill the whole family go pick up
have the drone have the drone pick up
his grandma
grandma getting picked up what the hell
drop her high up
oh that sounded like vince culley drop
her high up
there she goes
and splat onto the pavement side retire
she bounced off the funny thing about
this grandma is that she
is almost a great grandma her
her granddaughter's pregnant looks like
she won't live to see the day and she
bounces off the awning and hits the
cement side retired
wow that grandma sure did take a bounce
up
over the mailbox and
ground rule double
ah
we're all [ __ ] man you ever sit and
think about it about how actually [ __ ]
we are
and like how sad it is and then it's
like i brought a kid into this world and
it's like
he's gonna have to be the [ __ ]
leader of the resistance
i'm raising calvin to be the leader of
the resistance
that's what i'm doing
now
because it's gonna have to have he's
gonna have to do it at like 11 year olds
with 11 year old years old at this
exponential rate that we're going
robots are already attacking
so
i can't believe this rumba thing but i
guess i don't really care when i think
about it crazy
crazy
crazy
[Music]